[Music]
more than travel is all about getting
from A to B as quickly as possible
so let's see what traveling for fun is
all about good morning you might
recognize the name the Venice simple on
Orient Express has a centuries-old
reputation for luxury travel this
rolling stock is owned by the Belmont
luxury group its trains still go to
Venice or like this one on day trips
around the English countries night the
company wants to build on the trains
reputation for service other didn't like
the sound of ice clunking as the trains
moving so we study ground ice cubes for
her so they didn't make so much noise as
well as gourmet food guests climb aboard
to travel back in time splendid splendid
very nostalgic Belmond used to be called
Orient Express group until last year
when it rebranded so why drop one of the
most evocative names in history so we're
not just a legendary train we have
safaris we have extraordinary hotels we
have river cruises in Myanmar and so we
are much more in breadth and scope than
I think many people realized the Orient
Express brand is actually owned by
French railway company SNCF which is due
to launch its own service from Paris to
Vienna as competition hops up it seems
the golden years of luxury travel still
have a place in the 21st century Anna
Edwards Bloomberg